as we've talked about in many videos the
united states supreme court has a very
different role than the executive or the
legislative branches the executive
branch of course runs the government the
legislative branch they make the laws
and set the budgets and the supreme
court can rule that a law is
unconstitutional or it can interpret
laws in a specific case
and when the supreme court justices make
these decisions they try to follow the
principle of stara decisis which is
latin for let the decision stand it's
this idea of taking previous decisions
as an example and if we're in a similar
case now then just use that decision as
an example for this one
this is closely associated with the idea
of precedent
precedent in everyday language means
something that has happened before an
action or decision that we can use as a
guide or as an example
and that's exactly what the supreme
court tries to do if the supreme court
has made a previous ruling on a similar
case that would be considered a
precedent for this case the supreme
court has been often described as
umpires like umpires in a baseball game
even chief justice john roberts
described it as such when he was being
during his confirmation hearings and
it's this idea that they should be these
objective arbiters of what the truth is
of what is constitutional what is not
what does the law actually mean but we
know in reality these are human beings
and no matter how unbiased and no matter
how objective they try to be they still
bring to the table their views and their
experiences
and so even though this seems like a
very clean process there's definitely a
large degree of subjectivity here and
because the executive branch in
particular the president can appoint
supreme court justices there's
definitely examples in history of
changes in politics having long-term
effects on changes in the supreme court
for example
a significant case of overturning
precedent happens from 1896 to 1954.
in 1896 you have the plessy versus
ferguson case that we cover in several
other videos where the then supreme
court rules that laws that involve
segregation are okay
but then you fast forward almost 60
years and then the supreme court then in
brown versus board of education of
topeka ruled that no separate but equal
is not constitutional that segregation
is not okay
and this was influenced by this idea of
over time you had presidents who were
able to do
make judicial appointments to the
supreme court
as members of the supreme court died or
retired it went through a senate
confirmation process
and then these justices have life tenure
they can stay on the supreme court until
they pass away or until they decide to
retire
and so many historians would say that
this overturning of precedent was due to
a change in politics from the 1930s
through the early 1950s when you had
several terms of fdr and then you have
president truman who appointed justices
to the supreme court that would
eventually rule on brown versus board of
education and they would be more
pro-civil rights
and what's interesting about this is
even though presidents try to appoint
folks who they believe would maybe vote
the way they would or have similar views
many times it doesn't always work that
way for example president eisenhower who
was a republican appointed justice earl
warren who was a republican governor of
california but warren ended up being
famous for taking more liberal stances
than not including on brown versus board
of education